- Is it true that you
once spent a boys weekend?
I didn't know this, with
Ryan and Simon, in Vegas?
- You know look. I mean Kells,
look man, look, you know.
- Like that weekend was either
crazy or spent at a spa.
Like, like, like, I don't know.
- Exactly
- I, I called it our very own boy mitzvah.
- Okay. Okay.
- Boys attempting to still
try to turn the corner to man.
- [Kelly] Okay. You're still trying?
Grown men.
- I'm there. I'm there.
Can't speak for Simon and Ryan though,
but I'm definitely man, now.
- I'm not ...
You can't speak for them.
Um, well, we saw this old
photo of you and Madonna,
which, this is going back
to like, you know everyone.
But I heard, now this, oh, tell
me if this is a true story.
I heard that those are your
sunglasses that she has on,
and she might have taken them.
- She saw 'em and they
were in the next video
and I'm like, what
happened to my shades yo?
What the hell's going on here?
- [Kelly] She stole your shades
- But look, we love her. She's amazing.
- I love that though,
that your shades are in a Madonna video.
That's cool.
- Hey, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You gotta have glasses to see right?
- Well, and you have cool style.
Everybody knows this.
- [Kate] Yes.
- So she, even Madonna had ripped it.
- [Randy] Oh thank you
Kelly, that's so nice.
Kelly's so nice.
[Kelly] She was like, I want it.